[Musique]
chers citoyens le
où je n'ai plus d une autre menace
orientale grandi le péril vert
merci de ces vous la mode de
communication de masse de la russie se
répandre par le monde commentant sa
force et son rayon d'action des gâteaux
de propagande via les télévisions
ordinateurs et téléphones portables
plus de 12 milliards de vues de contenu
de contaminer sur youtube affecte votre
cerveau
vous des visions alternatives faites
vite
si vous commencez à osé questionner
évacués
chercher un abri
selon lui contaminés
[Musique]
ne croyez que les médias validé
restez à l'intérieur jusqu'à ce que ce
soit sans danger à l'extérieur si vous
êtes exposés auraient
verte et décontaminer votre esprit
les yeux les oreilles le cerveau liés
les idées claires et vous examinez
[Musique]
désormais vous pouvez vous défendre vous
et vos proches face aux armes de
communication de masse protégez-vous de
arte
donnez pas à l'ennemi la moindre goutte
[Musique]